[Music]
an easy anus I want one of those oh I
did that one pe oh that was not easy
oh good job that was not easy at all
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
guys didn't have classes in high school
we just chill and every day as long as
you're there you get an A no rat that
did not work drama
Oh woodshop PE you want to try not ask
me I think it depends on the school oh
okay that's time maybe that's why you're
so fast I'm just kidding sure let's all
have one on pops yeah
submitted by JK forever thank you
hundreds of YouTube channels have been
selling a cheating service to students
what why that's genius I always wanted
to do this I was like why don't they do
this on YouTube hmm yeah wait no really
that's brilliant that's awesome what are
you guys thinking what does the cheese
know I cheated so like it's like um if
you if you pay for this we'll we'll help
you cheat on your test back yeah like we
have tons of essays we have all of this
like for every single class and we can
write your [ __ ] reports or whatever
it is that they need to do right oh I
wrote this movie called the thinning
where I co-wrote it where the students
they use a contact lens to cheat oh I
wish that was real and it like hey it's
like a digital contact lens Oh
still I like that all right yeah so
that's exactly what every service that a
lot of YouTube stars are being paid to
sell to their a YouTube star as a
cheating service no no they're just
getting sponsored by these two these
youtubers are being sponsored by oh my
god yeah I got offered that's what
that's how I know like you did you're
perfect for to do the pan deal I didn't
do it why didn't you do it like you
believe in the product what was kind of
scammy
and then I
I didn't know like how legit it was I
just don't want to send people to
something that they're gonna pay for and
they don't get a good paper
I want that if they're gonna [ __ ] you
know I want them to like get their
money's worth and I didn't know like if
they're just gonna run with the money or
what you're gonna cheat you want
invention so GT I'm just against the
make sure they get their money's worth
you know yeah I mean because they're
cheating so if they cheat them out of it
then they're still just doing that it
was harder cheating than actually
studying not for me it wasn't I had that
[ __ ] down lock I was just like I know
exactly would have known that I caught
you yes I'm talked about you did college
all the college meanly all true yeah I
did it all I had to do is just [ __ ]
read what they told me to do in the
syllabus the syllabus told you
everything yeah yes apparently more than
250 channels are promoting this service
but I kind of don't want a shout on my
you guys want to know you can that's
what happens when you take away ads you
two people get does run to whoever's
gonna [ __ ] throw money at them yeah
what were they supposed to do huh what
were they supposed to do they're saying
that uh so BBC trending investigated
this and uncovered more than 1400 videos
with the total of more than 700 million
views selling this service that was a
lot is it good this is work yeah that's
the question well apparently like they
tried it and then they got like not a
great grade guarantee and a but they
didn't get an A or something I didn't
get it a and I got a see a pretty uh
they got a see I'm happy how do they do
that's pretty good how do they deliver
like the information to you live um no
this is mainly for essays what's up it's
a we have a sweatshop for essay writers
maybe because my idea was so a lot of
people needing India speak really good
English I mean will they write better
than they can speak and that's why we
use them for outsourcing call services
and stuff like that but a lot of the
guys that work at those places are they
they have degrees like their their
full-on like four year University type
peoples they have education so we could
just tell them he will pay you this many
money
or nests a and then we charge the other
guy a little bit more for the
transaction boom and you guys don't have
anything against cheating against the
kids not learning absolutely not
everything I want to talk about if you
are cheating successfully you have
learned to do something that is actually
gonna help you in life that's true if
you find a service like outsourcing
whatever uh Sam you have to do yeah
depends on how dumb they are right I
think it depends on the person I needed
school and I needed to do it honorably
but I also think the more stupid asses
there are the less competition for me so
[ __ ] them keep them dumb so that you can
be more successful yep I like no I mean
I don't know i don't i don't i didn't
want to promote that company because for
me it was just weird like i feel like
people will be cheating themselves if
they don't get what they're paying for
like if you pay for an education all
that [ __ ] you're paying for the
information the knowledge all that [ __ ]
right you want to do an honorable
[ __ ] thing not just breeze through it
but if your if your goal is to just go
to college and get a degree you don't
give a [ __ ] about the quality of
education you just want to party and do
all that stuff then that's your game
plan dude they shoulda taught creative
writing cuz i'm a writer
i had to learn all of that [ __ ] way
later like they and school ii did your
essay writing which is like the least
useful kind of writing i think in the
entire yeah yes i never you never use
this you're gonna like it
eat or like business like any any of
that stuff yeah when do you ever use
that you don't you do have creative
writing classes yeah no it's fine
it just sounds stupid to you and in high
school yeah right that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] well in even then it's more
like novel [ __ ] in high school and it
doesn't advance you to whatever the next
thing so i'll just skip that kind of
stuff mmhmm yeah mine was an elective so
i remember a scene creative writing but
i was like okay so i take this and
doesn't even count towards my [ __ ]
[ __ ] but no matter what every kid has
to write essays right yeah so it's like
what does that do i guess it's it's so
it helps what I like about essay writing
I guess if I had a defendant cuz I in
right now is it makes you form an
argument and debate so I like that
yeah aspect of it so maybe it is good in
that way I just debated myself that's
right
things work like that we're in the
debate team no but I wanted to be but I
but I thought those guys were [ __ ]
losers that's what I thought too
well I would have done it yeah that's
see that's what happens in high school
like there's a lot of things that we
wanted to do but we stopped ourselves
for doing it I was doing drama club so I
was already oh you should've just joined
from my love what made you do it drop a
club with this pepper with the baby
brother
honestly the changes in losers honest to
god the chicks yeah oh the drama club
girls in our school work we do Nate San
Diego they were choice premium they're
all trying to be actors Kobe beef Wow
yeah I used to do if I had the longest
Simon's like like 10 page 15 page I
would just try to quote as much I would
[ __ ] get the whole book two pages
[ __ ] parentheses and then boom I had
two pages of [ __ ] just straight-up
quotes from the book that's all I say
put that space in there one time I I had
to I didn't know I was blue that dude I
didn't know that there was a book report
due that day and then we have it gives
an all book report oh so I made up a
book and the story anyone and I still
got name that's dead teacher bought
teacher did not Google it teacher cause
back then there's genius it was very
slow what's the what's the book called
no idea what I remember it all well but
I totally [ __ ] is that doctors that
a half but then I thought I was like oh
I want to do this [ __ ] like an improv
though I would have done some [ __ ] like
read The Velveteen Rabbit like summary
real quick and then she's like is that
the Velveteen max I know you stupid [ __ ]
you're Nate Craig's I would have done
that in [ __ ] eleventh grade dude I
tried to pose a hungry caterpillar that
will be my book report I tried to my
first year college at her a [ __ ] a
book report that the professor wrote oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was hella funny okay cuz
they that's ballsy well I didn't know oh
wow so wow that's the problem with
universities it's really hard to cheat
because a lot of the professor's brought
the [ __ ] exactly and I learned that
really quick and I was my first year and
the person was laughing it was like just
let you know like I wrote the book and
other like you could do it again just
don't do that [ __ ] again I was like but
continue please okay I would that be fun
I would be laughing if my let me should
let me redo it I mean with my first year
of college so you know lesson learned
oh yeah very nice cheating that students
man a lot of people are saying that
YouTube has a responsibility watch just
what is this [ __ ] platform they're just
an act salesman agency they're just a
giant [ __ ] server yeah that sells ads
it's the individual yeah that's like all
this [ __ ] everyone's like YouTube's are
stopped someone is crypto currencies ads
everyone's losing their ass how can they
control [ __ ] right the other thing that
they have a moral responsibility to act
and and so YouTube is saying like well
just these essay writing services
they're not even illegal because they're
these services say this is just meant
for it to be out of the sample like for
you to just like like a guy it's like
when they saw those race car parts they
say oh this is for track only but
everyone puts it in a normal car yeah
and so yeah they're just saying like
YouTube should be removing anything
that's for promoting the service because
it's unethical
who's this school there's nothing more
responsible for kids not getting work
done than YouTube maybe video games
maybe but holy [ __ ] how many people
waste time on YouTube like the idea that
YouTube is an arbiter of responsibility
in some sense is insane yeah so many
people watching us right now that they
should be working on your paper okay but
youtube is so distracting that i as a
youtuber who makes a living off of it
get distracted because of youtube that's
why I do my work I can't even make
youtube videos because they're busy
watching you got too busy watching is
trying to be more family-friendly and AD
friend worst decision ever right I mean
I agree with you guys but if that's the
direction in which they're heading
that's why they're getting these
comments cuz they're like yo fees are
trying to clean a bunch of [ __ ] up why
are you promoting like to cheat well
they're not promoting oh it's the
channels that are doing well they're not
doing anything about it therefore it's
promoting but they can't that's like
people comparing a complaint in to
Twitter that all their Twitter accounts
are saying crazy [ __ ] or whatever
something more good right but then
hardly all of us and my like not like D
monetizing a bunch of [ __ ] and like you
know taking video that's directly
related to sales that's different than
what they're doing these are just
independent private channels promoting
whatever they wanted
yeah deal with it they do because then
if someone's like being hella nude they
take that down if they're like promoting
suicide or like talking about like crazy
[ __ ] they take that stuff down so they
also have like their guidelines that's
true right their guidelines guidelines
no YouTube guidelines is it is a two
word sentence or two words that put
together they give chen's a shiver down
my spine like YouTube's guidelines I'm
always like oh boy because it's always
whatever it is it's always like we just
want to facilitate a better more
positive community [ __ ] [ __ ]
obviously all they care about is just
more money in their pockets right um
volume by the without any attention
though that's the key word right I want
a lot of money without bad attention
right and this is bad attention so
that's I'm surprised that they're going
in that there if they're trying to go in
that direction that they would allow for
this to happen because it's gonna [ __ ]
with their dollars I mean what's next
man is that like hey don't do ads for
DiGiorno pizza because it's mad for you
I know it's actually better for you
right because they use natural
ingredients flash-frozen right out of it
you know I bet you I bet you say that is
a is a great pizza
if the [ __ ] sa people load the
shooting company or whatever if they
paid a [ __ ] top dollar they would
find a way to like promote them and like
make it fun no pizza to sponsor me
alright but I will tell you guys what
YouTube said so spokesman for YouTube
said that creators may include PETA
endorsements as part of their content
only the product or service they are
endorsing some complies with their
advertising policies that they do not
allow ads for essay writing and so paid
promotions of these services will be
removed when they discover them don't
help kids get good grades help kids get
fatter we love you
god bless america Thank You YouTube
goodnight thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]